los angeles has a high crime rate
but the violent nature of this attack
has shocked many here in west hollywood
paramedics treating a dog walker after
he was shot four times in the chest
with a semi-automatic weapon two dogs
were stolen
it very quickly emerged the owner of the
pets was singer lady gaga
a neighbor who witnessed the attack told
sky news
it felt targeted i looked over the fence
hearing the screaming because i might
have to go outside and see what's going
on and that's when the gunshot went off
right like that so i'm not going out now
so i turned around and ran back in the
house with my dog and my
partner and then i heard a second
gunshot and that's when i called 9-1-1
and there was a white car with two doors
open and
i saw a little scuffle there but that's
when i that gunshot happened it happened
literally 30 seconds i came back out and
i saw the guy on the ground
and everybody was on top of him just
like holding him even though it was
lady gaga's dogs i don't care a guy got
shot and he was
laying there on the ground like i
thought he was dead
lady gaga has now reportedly offered
half a million dollars for the safe
return of her two french bulldogs
no questions asked setting up an email
address in the dog's names
as a means of contact there are
shootings every day in los angeles
but the intense media interest in this
crime
is of course because of the celebrity
involved and now
the big money involved in terms of this
reported reward
could make other high-profile people
more vulnerable to this sort of crime
it's unclear if the attack was intended
to elicit a ransom
but there's concern it could inspire
others to carry out similar crimes
it sets a precedent that could backfire
um there could be copycat
robberies that take place with people
looking to get such huge windfalls from
celebrities
um and in general it kind of sends the
message
that some celebrities may be willing to
pay out a lot of money
without with few consequences in order
to get those types of belongings and
prize
possessions and animals back thankfully
the dog walker is said to be recovering
well
and police are continuing to search for
those behind the attack
sally lockwood sky news los angeles